[Music]
let's talk about the Oz the great and
powerful you're great in this movie and
you play it's fascinating because you
play Finley yeah a flying a flying
monkey a monkey
yeah and I didn't know what's a eight
but he's a monkey he's a monkey yeah
there's scary baboons but Finley is the
cute adorable little monkey sidekick to
James Franco's character and which was
great now some of you this backstage is
your personality really comes through
obviously there's a lot of like CGI
involved and everything but but you you
get to be funny you're away as Zach
Braff and you were really cracking me up
in the movie I was so thank you so much
and that was what was so fun about it
and I've never been in a big blockbuster
movie CGI movie like this with all these
effects but Sam Raimi our director
really let me improv and bring my own
humor to it and so a lot of those jokes
that I made up with James Franco ended
up in the movie and it was it was
awesome that's it now was it difficult
for you to shoot this because been
asking me this all week no movie was
such a hit across earth all all the
questions people are asking or like how
was this done because I wasn't just in
an audio booth and I thought you know
since I was coming on your show I could
really explain to people how it was done
because I was actually on set acting
with James and so I came prepared if you
don't mind not at all can I stand up
yeah sure go ahead
[Music]
okay now that's not
[Applause]
now basically Conan this is what I wore
on set at all times and apparently you
have continued to win well I'm feeling
good wearing this I the feeling seven
months feeling so happy that the movie
did well that I've decided to put it
back on very nice
now if your director could do me a
little solid and and do a little magic
you'll see that basically this is you
know I love the idea this is right now I
can just picture my mom tuning in my mom
tuning in right now and not knowing
what's happening so basically I floated
around the set like this and then the
animators would they videotaped my face
and they took all my facial gestures and
expressions and and then just animated
the little guy over me like hilarious
when you I feel like this is
I ruined it we did a thing on scrubs -
coffee all right
that's starting to look for new year
why I went down that way talk show of
the future this is how all talk shows
will be you don't sure if you ever
interview one like cliff cryogenic heads
ever come on your show this is me and
you know you always used to do that bit
in the year - yeah well they're the
future will be like this like you'll
have like people who are long dead but
their heads are still coming on your
show and they're promoting projects that
haven't been around for 40 years I love
this well we have a clip here from Oz
the great and powerful
a disembodied head another thing we need
to know about what scene you can bring
back my body if your director one mind
I'm feeling a little bit yeah I like
this a thank you I believe this is a
kind of sexy right
[Applause]
so I was covering it up in case I had a
moose knuckle
[Applause]
I'm floating a family movie you're not
allowed to say moose knuckle when you're
talking about this right now the Disney
people are backstage he's no longer an
open member of the Disney community
somebody's packaged someone Disney
definitely is concerned about me saying
moose knuckle
so the clerk actually saying it twice
the clip is is um me and James and so
you'll get the sense now that you see it
I was crawling along next to him as we
did this scene live let's take a look
we're gonna find this Wicked Witch
stealer Juan I'll get that big pile of
gold and you can have a nice pile of
bananas right bananas oh I see
because I'm a monkey I must love bananas
right that is a vicious stereotype there
aren't bananas of course I love bananas
I'm a monkey don't be ridiculous
[Applause]